Debra Messing gets candid about the
Willing grace reboot it was really an
incredible moment
[Music]
et spoke with the actress during the
Tribeca television Festival on Saturday
where she opened up about reviving the
hit show after 11 years after we shot
the first episode live in front of the
audience that's when it it hit me I mean
we all came out and we realized that
it's another show night like exactly
like 11 years ago and we all just got
very teary-eyed
you know our very stoic Jim Burroughs
had to wipe tears away it was really an
incredible moment and that was when I
realized we're really doing it Deborah
revealed she's happy the original series
finale ending was thrown out I was
surprised by it but when they explained
the reasoning it made complete sense to
me
because if we had kids then the show
would be about will and graces parents
and if we ignored the kids and just
focus on the four of us then we would be
bad parents and no one wants to see Will
and Grace be bad parents so we're back
to the four of us which is really where
where it all began and and where the
magic sort of lives messing also dished
on how the cast will celebrate when it
premieres Thursday September 28th on NBC
I need to talk to everybody we need to
have a screening like I mean we have to
have a viewing party if I bet I bet it's
gonna be at Sean's house Oh it'll be
it'll it'll be popcorn and and in our
pajamas
[Music]
you